I think without exception in each of
these counties I heard the exact same
thing nobody listened to us nobody
talked to us they opened up an office
someplace started handing out literature
couple months before the election then
they packed up to place a month after
the election and disappeared hi I'm Nick
Gillespie with reason TV and today we're
talking with ed Morrissey he is the
Grand Poobah hot air the very popular
and wonderful blog i know i read it
almost every day and he's the author
most recently of going read the two
million voters who will elect the next
president and how conservatives can win
them ed thanks for talking it's great
talking with you Nick so you write in
the book that in 2012 the Republican
Party did an autopsy why did they lose
in 2012 and in fact since george HW bush
won in 1988 there's only the only time
that Republicans have won a majority of
the popular vote was in 2004 that's
correct yes so you write GOP the
Republican Party has nationalized their
election strategy while Democrats have
gone hyperlocal and the results speak
for themselves what do you mean by that
in 2008 Barack Obama managed to outfight
Hillary Clinton for the nomination in
large part because of his ability to
organize effectively on the ground and
to connect emotionally with voters not
just by saying hi I'm Barack Obama I'm a
great guy on cool I'm hip but by talking
to people in these communities and
asking what is it that what are your
concerns what's the issues in your
community and then they would find
people to to convert into ambassadors
into each of these neighborhoods and say
you know what you know this issue that
we've been talking about well Barack
Obama's plan has addresses that and this
is a way it does that and they were they
were doing the pizza parties they were
doing all these two you know don't walk
in and I know I at various points I said
I suspect that you might have liked a
lot of the times you'd see these efforts
and you'd be like this is so stupid this
is because it's like that localization
it's kind of like it's personalization
it's individualization of politics that
we've seen in almost every other aspect
of our lives right and this is something
that both Republicans and Democrats do
outside of presidential elections
republicans over the same period of time
that we're talking about 2008-2012
Republicans have garnered more state
legislative seats since herbert hoover
they have one more governorships than
they've had in quite a long while I
think 31 or 32 governorships in that
period of time and even in the same
states that they lost to Barack Obama in
2008 and 2012 most of them had
Republican legislators and Republican
governors so the Republicans in these
local communities understand how to
connect to local voters but the
presidential election presidential
campaigns never actually did so I mean
part of you know the point of the book
and again which just has a massive
amount of reporting which i think is
fascinating in the way that you work
through all of these the main point is
that you have to go local in order to
national election so in these counties
all over the country in different kinds
of economic situations political
situations what you know is there a
simey to be attentive to what that area
wants or needs but what is the general
message then they have to start
listening to people now I'll tell you
what that provides first off it allows
them to understand what the priorities
are in these different counties and so
they can they can readjust their own
priority so they're addressing these
these issues the second thing is is it
provides a feedback loop to see whether
or not the message is working if all
you're doing is running national
messaging you're running it in every
single state and you're not listening to
people on the ground you have no
feedback loop and that's the reason why
a lot of a SAT around shocked on
election night 2012 which is how the
book opens up is you know this egg on
all of our faces about the outcome of
the selection and they had we've been
listening to them people that were in
these communities we would have known
where this election was going and we
would have known it early enough to
perhaps make some adjustments and
approach so you're missing that feedback
loop which is a key thing but also
politics should be peer-to-peer it
should not be a top-down lecture you
look at seven counties that are in
toss-up areas and basically your
argument is that whoever wins these
counties is going to win the national
election let's talk about Hamilton Ohio
yes Hamilton Ohio it's where Robert Taft
mr. conservative was from it has a long
lineage as what what did you find there
that Republicans or conservatives need
to do in order
to win a county that they should be
walking away with well first off they're
going to have to recognize that the
county has changed quite a bit
dramatically in fact over the last 46
years Hamilton County's lost about
twelve percent of its population now
that is very different than the other
counties that were looking at were
either the population has remained
stable although the demographics have
changed or there's been tremendous
growth for instance wake county north
carolina there's been a lot of growth it
was a fastest growing county in the
first decade of the 21st century in the
United States but Hamilton County's had
a net loss and a fairly significant one
Cincinnati is even worse they've lost
forty percent of their population over
the last fifty years and there's very
clear reasons why that happened the
manufacturing basically collapsed the
economy collapse those who were getting
up the Cincinnati Bengals collapsed the
Cincinnati Bengal Arabs yeah exactly i
know i'm at pittsburgh steelers spent so
maybe i shouldn't say this but in
Cincinnati forty percent of the
population flight it was the for the
most part was the forty percent who were
economically mobile enough to be able to
do that so you had Republicans that were
going out to the the collar counties
around hamilton butler being especially
one of those and even for those who
weren't republicans they were moving
into those first ring suburbs that
Republicans used to be dominant in so
those first ring suburbs are really what
lost Republicans the election in 2008
and again in 2012 because nobody
recognized that this is a much different
place it Hamilton's a much different
place and with different people who are
still open to their message if somebody
will show up and actually contextualize
it for their lives well and this goes to
some of the stuff that was in the
republican autopsy if the Republican
Party is aging it's shrinking in terms
of self-identification Gallup has says
about twenty six percent of americans
identify whether they register as a
Republican or not about twenty six
percent of republicans that's near a
historic low democrats are also sloping
down but do republicans have a message
say in hamilton county ohio where they
can go to two blacks to hispanics to
women you know kind of constituencies
that they haven't been doing well at
with but are set you know they said
after 2012 those are the people we got
to reach like what would be the message
in hamilton
County that would allow Republicans to
connect with those people well from the
people I talked to I talked to I talked
to an African American conservatives in
Hamilton County I talked to a few
different people out in Hamilton County
sure but you have to understand what it
is those local concerns are and then say
look this is what the conservative
agenda how the conservative agenda can
address that for instance one person his
father was the inventor of the halogen
light bulb that is in every form of
which was in every car now and he was
very proud about this and I said I got
to get this into the book because he was
he was very proud about this but he was
making a point about education because
education system in cincinnati has
really struggled since then and
Republicans can talk about school choice
they can talk about bringing the control
of schools back closer to the local
level I mean there are points in the
Republican agenda that really do speak
to this but you have to go in there and
find out well we bet this failing school
over here but you know there's a private
school that's just right down the road
it's accessible all we need to do is
free people up from being locked in
these eyes these public school systems
especially the failing ones so that
parents can make a choice for a better
education for their for their kids and
that is a message that will resonate in
wake county north carolina you talk to
an activist a young activist named
christian greevey and this gets to you
know what libertarians care bet he said
you know part of the problem with the
GOP is that he said quote it's openly
hostile to libertarians what you know
and I got to agree i mean on a certain
level you know when the libertarian show
up you know people make a couple of pot
jokes something about transgenderism and
then it's kind of you know and they try
and take you for granted and that's not
happening anymore what why should
libertarians want conservatives to win
the 2016 over it's a great question and
and look I mean you and I have been
talking about this for a long time first
off i think that the republican /
conservative agenda is oriented towards
limited government in a general sense
and i think that there are some areas of
difference and the conservative and
libertarian agendas but generally
speaking we're sort of marching in that
same
direction limited government smaller
government federalism subsidiarity you
know local control so I think on a broad
level that's true but you're never going
to make that sale unless you're reaching
out to Christian greedy and Sarah Remini
who's also in that chapter and to the
people in Jefferson County who say you
know we show up and the ratio of gray
heads to non gray heads is like nine to
one and nobody lets us in nobody lets us
in the club we have to be addressing all
these different groups and I think
libertarians fit very well within the
Republican coalition if we go to them
and say look this is what we're about
this is and we're going to disagree on
this but we're going to agree on more
can I ask I mean you mentioned Jefferson
County that's in Colorado Colorado is
legalized recreational pot and seems to
be doing a very good job of it they have
more tax literally more tax revenue than
they can spend violent crime is down
duis are down etc is that something that
the Republican Party and conservatives
can actually live with I think
Republicans and conservatives can at
least come to libertarians and say look
we believe in federalism so if Colorado
wants to do this and Colorado wants to
have the benefits and the consequences
of this then caller let Colorado do that
and we will tolerate that and see and
let it be the the the experiment the
laboratory of democracy that we like to
say about the state about states rights
you know part of the I think the
resistance both among libertarians but I
think also when you said like center
right I think to a lot of Americans is
that the Republicans talk one way I view
conservative Republicans they say you
know what we're going to cut government
we're going to cut the size scope and
spending of government except you know
last time that they had control of the
government George Bush increased
spending over his time in office by
about fifty percent real dollars he
started a couple wars that were not only
ultimately unpopular but poorly
prosecuted and I'd argue poorly
conceived you know we ended up bailing
out the auto industry we ended up
bailing out big banks we ended up
pushing for more drug prohibition many
of these civil liberties were in a
shambles many of these same policies
were continued by Obama and then the one
the things that Bush was actually kind
of good on which
was something like immigration now the
Republican Party is openly hostile to
immigrants so is that I mean is there a
way that Ted Cruz or Donald Trump given
the focus on immigration the focus on
control and authority is there any way
that they are going to convince whether
it's libertarians or the country at
large that there in the center as
opposed to way way far on the edge well
I mean I think part of this is when you
go talk to people in these communities
you look at prince william county for
instance where there is a heavy latino
presence in prince william county i
talked to tito Munoz who was known as
Tito the Builder in the two thousand
eight election great guy and and he
believes that Republicans can address
the immigration issue without abandoning
their principles but by explaining it
better and being more connected to those
communities and saying look we're about
right on legal immigration because
immigration is a federal government
issue and we've been even limited
government activists understand that
control of the national borders is a
federal government issue but but Tito
says look you just have to come and talk
to us to understand what it is that
we're saying about this you also have to
understand that not all Hispanics are
Mexican right not all Hispanics are that
caught up in the immigration issue and
even those who are of Mexican descent in
places like Colorado and also New Mexico
for that matter are sometimes fifth
sixth seventh generation Americans who
are more interested in the economy what
overwhelmingly I mean even even Iowa
voters listed immigration was like a
distant fourth it is sorry it is and so
some perspective on that would be would
be a good way to do that but the only
way you're going to get that perspective
is going out and talking to these photos
I'm hearing what they have to say well
so in a way I mean you're a great kind
of self-made blogger and new media
superstar and essentially what you're
saying is that you know politicians need
to be doing what you're doing which is
actually being in touch with the
community and building a community that
that speaks in two directions that it's
I think you said it's not a lecture or
sermon its its peer to peer to peer to
peer and even make it easier than that
they need to talk to the people in those
communities who have been successful at
that new national the last two
presidential campaigns would bring in
people
from the outside to run campaigns in the
swing states and these swing communities
without listening to anybody else on the
ground and two I think without exception
in each of these counties I heard the
exact same thing nobody listened to us
did we talk to us they opened up an
office someplace started handing out
literature couple months before the
election then they packed up to place a
month after the election and disappeared
and nobody was listening to us nobody
talked to us about our own constituents
the people that we know we could have
told them this message isn't working
this is not going to work you need to be
focusing on this issue or that issue and
here's how you can frame it and nobody
listened to them so I mean it's even
easier than this just getting just get
in contact with people who are
successful that's that's the that's what
you do this are you looking forward to a
contested Republican nominating
convention looking forward is probably
not the exact way that I would put this
but I think it's very likely now that
we're going to have a contested
convention i'll be there obviously
reporting on this and so it will be
interesting because it'd be the first
time if we go to a second ballot to be
the first time in I believe 68 years
that a Republican convention has gone to
a contested ballot or a second ballot
and for Democrats it was 1952 for us it
was nineteen forty eight and so it'll be
it'll be unique it'll be entertaining I
think to a certain extent and I think
the question that you have to ask
yourself coming out of a contested
convention is where people satisfied by
the process well enough to unite behind
whoever the nominee happens to be the
good news on that is that there's three
and a half months between the convention
and the election which is about double
the time that they've had traditionally
now for the last couple of decades so
there's plenty of time to sort of unite
behind a nominee and get the divisions
within the Republican coalition healed
up to some extent so you have some sort
of party unity but I don't know it just
you know it may end up being a good
lesson for the country too I mean to see
I mean I wouldn't be surprised and I
wouldn't shed many tears if the
Republican Party seriously implodes but
the idea of a contested election are
watching a party reconstitute itself can
be incredibly educational shirt and
edifying I mean just to see the
political process working well it's
still representative democracy we were
like
delegates to go represent us at the
National Convention we're relying on
those delegates to reach a reasonable
and rational conclusion that's that's
still representative democracy we've
been talking with ed morrissey of hot
air he also writes for the week and
fiscal times he's all over the place and
his latest book is going red the two
million voters who will elect the next
president and how conservatives can win
them at thanks so much thanks Nick for
raising TV I'm Nicholas